[Music]
london's waterloo station is one of
britain's biggest and busiest but not
today not this week three alternate
strike days on tuesday thursday and
saturday interspersed with three days of
minimal service mean travel misery for
millions this kind of disruption is just
ridiculous
everyone knows they're well paid how was
the journey
i'm coming from pakistan
over there i was supposed to take the
trend to
strafford it has been canceled four
times
from wimbledon it was fine but now going
to seven sisters is going to take me
very very long
so the journey will be one and a half
hours which is too much and everybody's
like messaged on the group work group
that there's heavy traffic on the roads
as well
so let's see here
only around 20
of the normal service is running and
only on half of the network mainly the
lines running into big cities in many
rural and regional areas there is no
train service at all
the dispute between the rmt rail union
and the employers network rail and the
train operating companies is largely
overpay and the impact of inflation on
workers wages but the government which
directly finances network rail has also
ordered it to find two and a half
billion dollars of savings network rail
says that's possible if staff accept new
working practices but the union says
that will mean 3 000 job losses and
jeopardize safety they want to rip up
our terms and conditions that we've
negotiated with the companies they're
even
threatening to lower pay and extend
working hours in the train operating
companies
and the majority of our members have not
had a pay increase for two to three
years so we've got a lot of problems we
will continue to do all we can to find
that sweet spot of compromise that is
affordable for for the employers
affordable for the taxpayer affordable
for the fair payer and the rmt and our
employers can live with at his regular
meeting of cabinet prime minister boris
johnson branded the strikes as
unnecessary and wrong he called on the
british public to stay the course during
what's expected to be a lengthy
disruption
the uk economy is experiencing the
combined effect of brexit the war in
ukraine and its effect on energy costs
as well as the inflationary pressure of
the post-pandemic recovery and rail
workers are not the only ones
complaining
the rmt is one of britain's strongest
unions some might say most militant of
unions with their ability to paralyze
the rail network during an industrial
dispute but the concerns that the rmt
have raised about the difference between
people's pay packets and the cost of
living at the moment the rate of
inflation are shared across many
different industries and other
professions teachers doctors nurses
local government workers all have pay
deals in the pipeline with the
government and they're likely to be
offered less than the rate of inflation
and that means a summer of discontent is
looming paul brennan al-jazeera waterloo
station
well the cost of living crisis has
triggered protests across the world in
the past few days from belgium to
zimbabwe the war in ukraine has pushed
up the price of food and fuel hitting
the poorest hard also making inflation
worse a sudden rise in demand for goods
as governments around the world opened
up after covet 19 lockdowns suppliers
were unable to ship products to
consumers fast enough and that's also
raised prices let's talk to given santa
who's live for us in london he's an
economist at king's college in london
good to have you with us so we know
what's causing the cost of living crisis
how long is it going to last how do we
solve it
well it's going to be at least this year
and next year is also going to be
difficult prices will still remain
elevated and we're looking at that
really damaging incomes across the globe
being pushed into hunger and destitution
here of course the uk a way of
industrial action that certainly could
be well repeated and on top of that
political instability as well the rising
price of making people worse off we
think 250 million more may be pushed
into extreme poverty this year and of
course governments toppled in pakistan
and sri lanka and the real key to
solving this is actually kind of a
two-pronged strategy on the one side
we'd finance ministries in rich
countries to give their citizens more
money to ensure they have enough cash to
get through this difficult moment more
international aid for those countries
who can't afford to give their citizens
money and central banks really to get
down inflation on their side by raising
interest rates as well as widening back
that quantitative easing program they
had that kind of accelerated throughout
the pandemic and given you you say 250
million people will be pushed into
extreme poverty where are those people
which countries are being worst affected
by this
well of course it's those nations that
are low-income nations particularly
especially those who have been kind of
liable or rather depend upon imported
wheat we know for example that global
food prices going higher it's really
going to hit the poorest people in the
poorest nations and sub-saharan africa
for example around 40 percent of
people's income is spent on food
compared to less than 20 in kind of rich
nations across the globe but as
generally speaking with this cost of
living crisis it's those right at the
bottom and in terms of nations those who
are the poorest nations what about
richer nations i mean
it's affecting
people everywhere isn't it i mean lots
of people are having to tighten their
belts and go without even basic staples
quite often
yeah that's certainly true in the uk we
already face a hunger crisis here 2.6
million kids going hungry we think
that's going to get worse again
specifically in the uk it is those who
are at the bottom and the lowest incomes
who are suffering the most and that's
because they spend more of their income
on food and on fuel to heat their homes
we think average inflation in the uk
will hit 11 percent later this year but
those are the lowest income states and
inflation rate of 15 a year so really
it's up for governments to kind of put
cash into families pockets but look
let's be clear rich nations did get
through a once in a century pandemic
they locked down their economies it's
certainly within their power to ensure
that no one suffers during this crisis
really good to talk to you given many
thanks indeed for being with us steven
sander there at king's college in london